good morning John sometimes it's hard to
figure out what to make a video about so
you call your brother and you ask him
and he reminds you that he's really
stressed out right now maybe a little
bit sad also he just wants a video about
humans being joyful and amazing so John
here is a video about people being
joyful because their fruits and
vegetables are amazing humans have been
selectively breeding plants since there
was agriculture resulting in some pretty
fantastic transformations like check out
this ancient ancestor of the carrot no
thanks in this seedy little green banana
ball I think I'd rather not thank you
and my very favorite agricultural
transformation is spindly little grass
seed here was apparently useful enough
that we kept breeding it and breeding it
and breeding it until finally we got
frickin corn what and we remain very
good at this so good that we just do it
for fun and we end up with ludicrously
large fruits and vegetables and I like
them and I love to see the people who
are so happy about them let's start out
with a smallest of the big the largest
apple ever only four pounds also on the
list of surprisingly small large things
is the largest ever potato only eight
pounds so if you extend that to sweet
potatoes lebanese farmer camille sim hot
would have something to say about with
his 25 pound sweet potato 1998 alaskan
farmer and mechanical engineer john
evans grew the largest ever cabbage over
76 pounds and until this year john evans
was also the record holder for the
world's largest carrots but this year
the title was taken by Minnesotan chris
quali with his 22 pound carrot that is
frankly upsetting to look at this year
is tim st. he did not grow the largest
zucchini but i did very much like that
picture of him holding it likewise look
at this happy woman who has grown the
world's largest pineapple it's Christine
McCallum thank you and of course as long
as we're talking about happy people
holding their giant vegetables here's
Peter Glazebrook holding his world's
largest onion like a baby oh yeah Peter
Glazebrook and his onion are the cutest
thing I love that trees and bushes will
often have a structural problem growing
giant fruits which is why this world's
largest tomato is being held up by some
pantyhose weirdly enough there's a
variety of lemon called the nine pound
lemon tree that grows nine pound lemons
or more and somehow it manages this just
fine and there are a few nine pound
lemon trees at Epcot in oral
where I think the world's largest lemon
was harvested 15 pounds now beating out
all this stuff by a lot are the gourds
not the band there is a band called the
gourd melons squashes cucumbers are all
members of the gourd family and gourds
can grow very big world's largest
watermelon grown by Chris Kent in
Tennessee weighed in at over 350 pounds
and remember that the largest thing on
this list so far with that 76 pounds
this is a big watermelon but it is
nothing compared to the biggest pumpkin
now here's the situation the pumpkin is
the biggest fruit or vegetable so if you
grow the largest pumpkin you have grown
the largest fruit John I didn't know
this until I started researching this
video but there are giant pumpkin
festivals all over the world so the
fight for who has the largest pumpkin is
hard-fought and in 2016 the winner beat
the previous record by over 300 pounds
Mateus Villa mine of Belgium hit it out
of the parks 2,600 pounds look at this
man
he is a star but these festivals tend to
be held around October 10th which I know
is an important day for other reasons so
we don't know if Mathias is pumpkin is
gonna get beat out in 2017 John the
world championship of functions way off
it's this Sunday I don't know about you
but that's gonna take over all of the
anxiety I have over anything else that's
all I'll be thinking about is this
wonderful pumpkin championship nothing
else is gonna stress me out just be at
peace you'll be fine your book is great
people will love it and John I will see
you on Sunday when I flatten New York
City on the very day of the European
Championship of pumpkins way off best of
luck to all the pumpkin competitors at
all of the pumpkin festivals I think
that you and your pumpkins are just
great in the end you can turn them into
a canoe and there is actually a canoe
race that sooth pumpkin canoes humans
Wow